Hilary Duff is not here for body shamers  we live in a world that's obsessed with  bodies and especially in my industry the  younger star is currently on vacation in  Hawaii with friends and family and of  course she got paparazzi in a swimsuit a  little shell-shocked by the whole thing  well Hilary has some thoughts on those  PAP shots and shared them on Instagram  writing in part quote since the websites  and magazines that love to share celeb  flaws well I have them my body has given  me the greatest gift of my life my son  Luca five years ago I think now more  than ever I appreciate my body Hilary  who turns 30 next month continues with  quote ladies let's be proud of what  we've got and stop wasting precious time  in the day wishing we were different  better and unclogged oh and she topped  it all off with the hashtag at  kiss-my-ass standing until I'm done and  then I am done  [Music]